Herkese
[Müzik]
selamlar Efendim hepinize
sevgili gençler
bu hayat sevgi ile başlıyor ve ne kadar
sevgi dolu olursan o kadar güzellikleri
verebiliyorsun insanlara
Ben 13 Mart 1969'da Gaziantepte doğdum
ve bir Gaziantep sevdalısıyım ve 1800r
dayanan bir Gaziantepli ve bununla gurur
duyuyorum ve bunu gelen misafirlerime de
anlatıyorum vee o kadar iyi anlatıyor
muşum ki beni kültürel seçtiler ve
bundan da çok mutluluk duydum
Aslında şöyle başladı Benim Hikayem Ben
önce sivil toplum örgütlerinde çalışmayı
bu ve oradan kazanımlar almayı çok seven
biriyim ve sivil toplum örgütlerindeki
organizasyon işlerini yaparak Ben
aslında bunu kendimi meslek edindim ve
98 yılında bin 900 18'de iki arkadaşımla
birlikte
bir organizasyon firması kurdu ve bu
organizasyon firması düğünler açılışlar
kokteyller beni çok farklı bir
güzelliğe ve ortama etti Şimdi
insanların hayallerini
gerçekleştiriyorsunuz ve benim yapımda
en büyük misyonum şu karşımdakini mutlu
etmek Aslında pipet başkanının söylediği
gibi bütün gençlerin hobisi olsun
istiyoruz ve ben hobi mesleğe
dönüştürmüş tüm ve insanları mutlu
ediyorum Çünkü insan seviyorum
Şimdi ben Tabii bunları anlatırken şimdi
diyeceksiniz ki işte karşımızda hayalini
gerçekleştirmiş bir kadın konuşuyor ama
bunun için çok emek ve çok çaba sarf
etmek gerekiyor Bu emekliler Sen kendini
hayal ettiği süre bu geçiyor öyle güzel
yaşanmışlıklar var ki hepimizin
hayatında ve bunlar sizi doğru yola
götürüyor şimdi ben iki arkadaşımla
birlikte bu organizasyon firmasını
kurdum ve Gaziantep'te hiç yok E Şimdiki
gibi
internetten bakıp da nerede ne var
onları bilemiyorsun Biz Gaziantep çok
sıcak bir bölgeye b&w
kurdeleleri bağlayıp sandalyeleri
giydirerek başladık bu işe şimdi çok
müthiş sandalyelerde var masalarda var
işler o kadar daha kolaylaştı ki biz
zoru başardık zoru başardığımız için
buradaki
ekibi Benim amacım Hep de hayalim içimde
yaşadıklarım şuydu ben bu kadar eşyayı
taşımak istemiyorum Ben şunu yapmak
istiyorum Bu eşyalarıyla birlikte gelen
konuklarımıza sunum yapma bu ve ondan
sonra
O
benim 11 yıl organizasyon firmasıyla
görev aldıktan sonra kendi işletme açtım
kendi işletmemde hep şunu savundum ben
Gaziantep'in güzel lezzetlerini
sandıktan çıkan lezzetleri sunacağım
gelen konukları mı bu çok inanılmaz
dünyaca ünlü mimarlarla Çalıştım
danışmanlarla çalıştım ama danışmanları
mayıp Şunu dedim beni ben yapacağım
Çünkü ben anneannemin Baba annemin
yaptığı yemekleri gelen konukları
anlatmak istiyorum ben de gidiyorum
geziyorum
bakıyorum ama hep Eskişehir'den
başlıyorum Çünkü eski şehirler şehrin
kimliğini kanıtlıyor Aslında şehrin
nasıl bir değere sahip nasıl bir tarihe
dokuya sahip olduğunu Açıklıyor ve biz
biz ekibimle birlikte
böyle bir Misyonu bu üstlendik ve
Eskiden
Atalarımız ne yemek yapıyorsa ben gelen
konukları ma onları sundum o maç yaptım
ve bütün şehitlerin bana dedi ki inandım
amaç satmaz da hani biz böyle bir şey
yapmadık daha önce dediler burada ilkini
yapacağız dedim ve ilkini yaptık Şu an
en çok Ovat satıyorum ben
her şeyi ilkini yapmak çok önemli ve
Hani hop olarak birşeyleri üstlenmek
insana çok fark kazanımlar getiriyorsa
Siz mesleğinizde o bu hale dönüştürün
Siz mesleğini o bu haline dönüştürdüğünü
sürece yaşamınızda çok mutlu olacak
çünkü mutlu olmadıkça Siz çalışamaz
sınız hiç çalışma prensiplerinde çok
sert bilginidir yani vuruşta çok yumuşak
bir olabilirim çağır Burada arkadaşlarım
da var görüyorlar beni
Ben
bunu yanısın yanı sıra
başarı
mükemmeliyetçilik de gizli
hepimiz ne kadar mükemmel bir şekilde
işimize sarılıp ve onu sahiplenir
sackpack dünya birincilikleri de geliyor
benim Mesela annem bana hepsini söylerdi
ben işe başladım hep Annem şunu söylüyor
dünya birincisi olacaksın ve ben anneme
şunu söylüyorum Anne benim işim de dünya
birincisi olmaz ve Annem hep bunu
söylüyor dünya birincisi olacaksın ve
ben
tarihi dokusunda da en iyi derecede ve
dekorasyonda dünya üçüncüsü oldum yani
annelerinizi ve tarihimize sahip çıkın
ve bunu
kendimize misyon edenin dinky Evet
benden önce başarmışlar ben de bunu çok
iyi şekilde başaracağım şu ve temiz
başarı odaklıyız ve benim iki tane
torunum var İki çocuğum var bir kızım
bir oğlum ve hep eğitimlerini çok iyi
yerlerde yapsınlar istedim eğitim çok
önemli fakat kendini geliştirmen kendini
yetiştirme no anlamda eğitimden de
önemli tabii ki aile doluyor insan ilk
eğitimini çok sevgi dolu bir ailede
büyüdüm ben Biz üç kız kardeşiz ve çok
güzel sofralarımız olurdu babam Eve
gelmeden Annem bizi masaya oturmaz önce
babam gelecek babam gelecek diye bir
heyecan yaşardık Biz masaya oturur hep
birlikte yemek geldik tek hayalim şudur
benim çok uzun masalarda keyifli
sohbetler de misafir ağırlamak ama şimdi
onu mesleğe dönüştürdüğüm için gelen
konuklarımıza Birlikte çok uzun
masalarda yemekler veriyorum çok uzun
masalarda sofralar
bu ve buna o kadar mutlu oluyorum ki ki
mutlu olduğum için de
takdir görüyorum insanlar diyor ki
evinizde ağırlamış gibi ağlıyorsunuz
bizi bu aslında benim rol yaptığım şey
gerçeği yansıtıyorum gerçeği
yansıttığını sürece şu hepiniz Bunu da
çok başarılı olacaksınız ve lütfen
hepiniz her zaman Kendinizi çok iyi
gelişti
şimdi İnsanın beyni her farklı yerde
algılıyor her şeyleri farklı yönde
algılıyor yani Bizler hayatımız boyunca
ben bu arada İki tane ortağım vardı Biri
İşletme mezunu
ortağımın bir otu mezunuydu ben erken
evlenmiştim ve erken anne olmuştum ve
lise 1'den ayrıldım şıma Maya inanın
insan ilişkileriniz çok iyi olduğu süre
O sizin
kazanamayacağını hiçbir şey yok yok o
kadar güzel kazançlar elde ediyorsunuz
ki insan sevmekle ve hayalin peşinden
gitmekle ama gece gündüz Ben bunu
yapacağım ben bu doğruların arkasında
duracağım diyorsanız başarı hepinizin
elinize zaten şimdi ben çocuklarım hep
şunu söylerim çocuklarım
lütfen
Arkadaşlarınızı arayın ama yalnızca bir
şey istediğimizde değil ve Merhaba
nasılsın Seni özledim diye arayın
hepiniz
Çevrenizi
Arkadaşlarınızı dostluğunuzu
o kadar güzel yaşayın ki bu Network şu
an Amerika'da en önde olay Neden biliyor
musunuz insan çevresiyle ile ve
arkadaşlarıyla dostlarıyla
bozukluklarıyla bir arada yüceltiyor ve
ben şimdiki gençlere şunu öneriyorum
lütfen hepiniz birbirinize destek olun
bu ve
bu başarıyı hep birlikte dedim şimdi
bana şunu söylüyorlardı işte Nasıl bu
kadar Antep'e anlatıyorsun yani Antep bu
kadar Antepli olmak senin ayrıcalık
diyorsun Nasıl bir ayrıcalık bu Antepli
olmak şöyle bir ayrıcalık kökenlerimiz
dengeliyor Bence bizim çocuklarımız
nerede okursa okusun Robert De Koç'ta
Harvard'da kendi memleketlerine dönüyor
ve kendi
şirketlerini Oradan aldıkları kültürle
değerle çok daha güzel yerlere getiriyor
ve bu Antep'in başarısı Demet Sabancı
bana şunu söyledim yine ben bunu
Adana'da yapamadım ama Gaziantep bunu
başarmış
Evet çünkü Gaziantep eski gelenek ve
göreneklerini
sahiplenmiş ve kendi çocuklarıyla yeni
nesille de bunu bütünleşmiş
mi Evet Teknoloji çok nereye gidiyor ama
hala pandemi de bize bu
mutfakları Evde yaptığımız ekmekleri
yemekleri ve Buluşmaları yarın ne kadar
önemli bir değer olduğunu gösterdi Şimdi
hepimiz
Biz aile olarak
eğitimin öğretimin
minicik evlerde başladığını biliyoruz ve
sevgiyle başladığını biliyoruz
bütün annelerden babalardan da benim
ricam hakikaten çocuklarınıza önce en
büyük aşığı Siz aşılayın Sevginizi verin
Sevginizi verdiğiniz sürece çok
merhametli çocuklar yetişecek ve bu
dünya gelecek çok daha iyi yerlere
gelecek benim açımdan Tabii ki şimdi
gençler çok daha farklı bir düşünüyor
herkes
ve Ama ben buna inanıyorum ki tüm
gençler hep birlikte kendi Hobileri ile
ele ve kendi çalışma prensipleriyle
hobilerini meslek edinip bu hayatta çok
iyi yerlerde olacak
şimdi Ben Ökkeş bana ilk
Paris te konuşmacı olmanı istiyorum
inanın dediğim dedim ki hangi kimlikle
olmamı istersin Ökkeş dedim şimdi daha
önce biz yok Keşke birlikte de Çalıştık
şimdi iş ortamı çok farklı ama hayat çok
daha farklı çünkü kesinlikle iş
ortamında çok ciddi bir disiplin
gerekiyor Yani o disiplini ve
çalışkanlığı kendi elemanlarını ekibine
de yansıtmayan gerekiyor hepimiz Bu
doğrultuda Hani baş Neyse Arkadakiler de
öyle ya bu doğru Allah rahmet dediğiniz
sürece Siz de mutlu olacaksınız
O benim şimdi Mucize iki tane torunum
var
İnşallah sizler de bir gün ve yaşayın
onları ve onların mutlu çocuk olması
için elimden gelen her türlü gayreti
gösteriyorum şu an çünkü mutlu olduğun
zaman her güzelliği Ulaş'a biliyorsun
mutlu olduğun zaman şu an tüm Yollar
size açılıyor Yeter ki siz çalışma
azmini
ve Merhameti
o
huzuru elinizden bırakmayın
ya
ben en hepinize sonsuz teşekkürler
ediyorum
şehitlerimize başsağlığı diliyorum
yaralı olanlara şifa diliyorum i
O çok teşekkür ediyorum sağlık bakalım